hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
I'm Jim Jarrah and this is Tamara Jessa
we just saw King Kong cool and i'ma go
oh yeah Council I have only seen the
Peter Jackson and I only knew the CEO
Jackson as you said Peter Jackson
professor glad I just knew it was the
jack black one but you only come maybe
that day but you are looking to calm
fishy annatto yes I'm a bit of a yes the
19th the original 1933 King Kong is
still remains one of my favorite movies
of all time but like I grew up watching
the 1976 one was never dull Jeff Bridges
was yes was the guy in it and we should
yeah and he had like long hair and beard
stuff so I guess I just don't love him
I'm Jessica Lane just do it yes Jessica
like it was her first music so that was
the one I grew up with and with a big
ape ooh
you know those monsters or whatever
what's not to like anyway pretty clear
on that variable so but then when I saw
the 1933 version I was like fell in love
with it and ever since it's been with my
favorite movies and I've liked the
Pierre Jackson one of the good remake
wasn't perfect it has you know a little
long I saw the trailer for this one I
was kind of like yeah it looks so so I
don't know it looks like it they're just
building enough to be a fight between
him and Godzilla you know thanks video
and so I wasn't super excited about it
but you were excited about it okay so I
saw the trailer and I was like um I I
mean just it was like a good action film
and like it's King Kong like whatever
I've no surprise there but I like the
comedy that they brought in with Justin
oh yes thank you john c reilly I was
like okay that's not what I was
expecting because I'm saying earlier
he's like such a specific type of comedy
when you see him you like oh I'm going
to get this weird Will Ferrell as clay
comedy and less now I was expecting with
that so that could be interesting you
can be very skeptical which I enjoy if
you like love them and so it came up to
me in the studio and you're like are
they saw the recent trailer and I'm kind
of excited like I want to fully commit
yeah that's the same time I was like
here and I'm kind of on board you know
it should be like a fun adventure and
that's where like income should be it
should be like this you know super movie
or whatever are very long right yeah I
guess my initial thoughts are I enjoyed
what I thought I was going to enjoy I
enjoy the comedy I wasn't too taken out
of it by like any like weird CGI
visually it was shot really really well
um that they didn't it was it was like
it was a bright kind of movie like it
and it was beautiful like the landscape
and stuff it wasn't is like harsh or
scary and stuff is yeah yeah most
iterations of King Kong usually are I
kind of want to be there right yeah it
was like look like a nice place to
vacation but I did look
uncomfortableness enter like there was
like bugs anywhere like that there was a
cool detail there like there were flies
on everything and like mosquitos and
okay so even if you can see if there's
like sound effects right right right you
know all the times they were booked
beside characters were more interesting
than the main characters right Tom
Hiddleston Mills's June a little bit of
perfect and like first exactly cool
backstory and it would I care to have
the potential to be really cool and I'm
not saying this is his bad a thing is
like kind of maybe description right
just bland kind of bland like not bad
just just there yeah they didn't like
flesh out any of the characters really
it was like it was kind of hard to
determine who the main characters were
because they kept starting with these
new characters and we went on further
and further you can like oh that person
still alive why are they still like oh
they're dead okay nevermind yeah I guess
you don't go to I mean well I can
necessarily go to be like this
like blown away by you know keep
characters most people just want to go
and see that's a big yeah yeah you want
to King Kong and I see action-adventure
yeah and it pretty much delivers on that
I thought the action sequences and stuff
like that were well done
it is very choppy you know it was kind
of like them we didn't know what it
wanted to be it's like it's sometimes it
really took it so seriously it was like
like a like a vietnam war drama and then
it's unlike the next turn it would be
like a ridiculous comedy my guy felt
like Jesse Reilly like legitimise like
oh okay this is supposed to be fun and
then he almost has a main character yes
but he turned out to be all that him
doing like his arc yes when I heard that
they were doing this so Devereaux's kind
of like wow I can see them set up
whatever in the Godzilla versus King
Kong type movie base because they all it
is it's just really just a setup because
that's all it is it doesn't really offer
much else other than that I will say
like it's a different take on the King
Kong story or whatever it's not it's not
a remake of the same movie that we've
seen before
so at least it did that but it did it
did feel choppy and feel a little bit
like the movie didn't know exactly what
it was at times the ending felt super
rough yeah big time I wanted this script
to like there's not there's not any like
surprise in this film and I mean it's it
get the kink off there's not engage with
but I wanted like like I just maybe like
something like just really really
obvious things that happen for the story
but like like john c reilly was like oh
don't go into the you know death camp
here and then they're like gonna do it
anyway you're like okay well bad things
can happen bad things happen i mean it
was just like very formulaic i guess
right right
hannah not a way that was like home
again but just the way it was like okay
yeah yeah right it was it was very very
predictable one step like we've seen
you've seen the movie the the layout of
the film yeah
okay so many times I know but again
that's why you're seeing this film
run also I'm not really mad at me it's
the stratified review like I landed on
Jackson hold on three bus guy and he
says I didn't feel a little called back
yet
I like really wanted to be like yell at
you guys like his character really the
only one with any real motivation but
it's like you pick it out you know
immediately what is going to happen I
know your ass is like it I really did
not like him it oh yeah he was playing
am like he was he was Captain Ahab and
Kong was the white whale like you know
it was like it was totally Moby Dick
thrown in the middle the King country I
didn't know for sure everything at first
I kind of liked the way it ends you know
are we going in this boiler sure - oh
yeah let's just watch a few goes home or
whatever and it's like old 8-millimeter
footage you know which is kind of a cool
touch this is nothing like going over to
his life and finally meeting his kid and
then getting to have like you know his
hot dog and beer and I was yeah that was
like I love that so I don't know
anything about kiha meet his friends but
I how did you lose it it was just a
security New York and he's right I
really like so the giant oxes they were
so cute
giant spider was super scary oh that did
the octopus paying attention and it was
like other creatures and other things
but like what main thing was like the
lizard guy yeah I don't know if it was a
purpose or not but they're kind of a
call to x2 a very brief character that
was in the original 1933 King Kong
yeah they were okay I kind of felt like
I seen them in movies before they
weren't like terrifying
yeah right I mean I wish it were a
little scarier yeah but I liked his
design and I thought was cool awesome it
was really cool yeah he looked like they
like a little bit of a no much to the
1933 because he doesn't look quite like
an ape he's a little bit mannish and
he's more of like in between kind of you
know I wish you would have seen a Nance
though I did read I was looking forward
to this yeah I went to the begin yeah
they like creaking and I was like ah
hell yeah the Yale team overall I guess
I enjoyed it I'm glad that I thought
yeah no III don't
it was fine I thought I did enjoy most
of it you know I didn't I wasn't like I
guess me because my expectations were a
little bit lower so yeah like if you can
entertain me for you know two hours
yeah that's fine if I get to see King
Cotton like right some big monsters and
it looks cool there and I'm glad I was
selling a gun that I'm not doing this
alone because you know a lot about King
Kong and I know my gosh I got got an
hour just be sitting here like I was so
bad and here's live cable is part of it
was my excitement to do it was just
because I love King Kong I was like
alright cool again didn't talk about
King Kong I guess you have to join me
for the Godzilla's one now yes yeah they
like I was I thought maybe they'd be
like a tiny like cheese or something or
like you know Easter egg at the end they
would be like but it was like no
placement like no yeah this was
happening like nearly all the monsters
you know basically they're going to
introduce like every kid you know Mothra
and you know Rodin so everything should
be like at pictures of that was like
this is what we're hearing but it's
clearly like like okay
I never say to the end of movies I would
like have my popper in the hands like
all right let's go awesome thank you
thank you see you next week laughs I had
your anything